[Music]
hey
you all right
[Music]
oh what a slap that's emmy award-winning
actress julianna margulies and the good
wife now she's no stranger to tv dramas
margulies first made a name for herself
in the 90s in the hit show er where she
played nurse carol hathaway that part
earned her her first emmy now she's
taking on a new role of laura peterson
on the morning show peterson is a
veteran journalist who rebuilt her
career after it was derailed decades
earlier because she was gay take a look
i kept my private life to myself because
i had to
it was 1997 and it was painful
and it sucked but i slowly quietly tried
to live a life that was more truthful
not with the world but with my inner
circle
but people talk
they're fascinated by who's gay and
who's not for some reason next thing i
know yda is handing me my walking papers
they fired you of course they did why
would i have quit that job
at that point in my career
i mean it wasn't explicit they didn't
literally
hand me a pink slip but when you're not
wanted
people find a way of letting you know
um word's so true julianna margalize
joins us right now good morning good
morning good morning thank you for
joining us now you've said that you like
to relate to every character that you
play how do you relate to laura
oh well um
it could be it could be my age now maybe
but um
you know you get to a place in your life
and i think the same thing happened with
laura where you go this is who i am
take it or leave it i'm not gonna i'm
not interested in pretending i i have no
skeletons in my closet i'm not hiding
i'm telling the truth and if you don't
like it i guess then you're not in my
orbit is it weird for you to be sitting
here on this set
playing you play an anchor and
correspondent on a morning show now
you're here on a morning show we have
your graphics package on the wall
do you even know where you are right now
no it's a little surreal um it's surreal
also because the last time i was on a
set that actually looks quite like this
was the morning show set and that was in
april um it is it's weird except
honestly
i don't i i couldn't do what you do
it's early every day we couldn't do what
you do
about it at least you don't have to
memorize your lines right you get to
read them you said recently that you've
been stopped on the street uh by people
who love the morning show why do you
think they're connecting to this
character in particular it's so bizarre
you know i did the good wife for seven
years
22 episodes a year wow and i would walk
in and out of places and people would
only recognize me if they heard my voice
and then they'd turn around and say oh
you're the but now i walk my dog at
night with a mask and a baseball hat on
and i have people saying i love you on
the morning show and i'm like
wow i guess there's something about
maybe it is you'd have to ask them i
don't know but i think there's something
about laura where
the way they wrote her honestly i think
anyone whoever had played this role i
got lucky enough to do it but they wrote
her so
openly and honestly it's refreshing and
it's sort of i think something at least
i aspire to be more like her in in just
living your truth right so maybe that's
what it is i don't know
you've talked about preparing for roles
and wanting to know the history
who did you speak to or what guidance
did you get to prepare for this news
anchor woman who's accomplished so much
and please include a cbs person
yes that would be nice that'd be a nice
plug but who was your inspiration who
did you well you know first of all i got
the role in the middle of the lockdown
so it was november of of 2020
and um there weren't a lot of places i
could go or
or research i could do outside of my own
home
but i happen to i know this is going to
sound um i'm not meaning to name drop at
all but i happen to know diane sawyer a
little bit i know katie couric i know
george stephanopoulos through the years
gail king is a good friend of mine and
she's not here today so i i have spirit
i have been able to
to sort of get a taste of of what
journalists go through and what they do
and i tried to
emulate uh laura on sort of a a a mix of
all of them because she she is uba's
star of night she has her nighttime show
but she also is a woman who
did field work and she's also a woman
who got fired for being gay so she had
to start from scratch you know she was
on a morning show got fired and started
from scratch and came back because she
was a great journalist not because it
not because it had anything to do with
her sexuality now speaking of her
sexuality you said you didn't hesitate
to play a gay character not a spark
conversation in the lgbtq plus community
um saying well actors and actresses in
that community can better portray a
character like her what is your response
to that
well um i i can understand that um my
response also would be we're all making
assumptions as to who i am
and what my past is and what all of our
paths are i understand 100
that i can't play a different race
right but i am an actress
and i am supposed to embody
another character
whatever their sexuality is doesn't
matter to me the same way
uh watching a gay person play a straight
person are you telling me that because
i'm a mother i can never play a woman
who's never had a child
or
you know if you've never been married
that you can't play a married woman i
mean you you have to be careful
yeah on on where you're drawing the line
there we're actors right we're supposed
to embody a character
regardless of their sexuality when it
comes to
race
uh and gender that's a whole different
story right and and i 100 agree with
that right so that's that's
that's my stance on it well well said
and i look forward to watching the rest
of the season of the morning show thank
you brianna margelise thank you so much
for joining us